thank you very much everybody thank you
so America continues to wage you all-out
war to defeat the virus this horrible
horrible virus you see how terrible it
is especially when you look at the
numbers from yesterday and we explained
why we're extending our nationwide
guidelines to slow the spread for 30
days together we have the power to save
countless lives we are attacking the
virus on every front with social
distancing economic support for our
workers rapid medical intervention and
very serious innovation and banning
dangerous foreign travel that threatens
the health of our people and we did that
early far earlier than anyone would have
thought and way ahead of anybody else in
this time of need I know that every
American will do their patriotic duty
and help us to achieve a total victory
as governments and nations focus on the
coronavirus there's a growing threat
that cartels criminals terrorists and
other malign actors will try to exploit
the situation for their own gain and we
must not let that happen we will never
let that happen today the United States
is launching enhanced counter narcotics
operations in the Western Hemisphere to
protect the American people from the
deadly scourge of illegal narcotics we
must not let the drug cartels exploit
the pandemic to threaten American lives
in cooperation with the 22 partner
nations u.s. Southern Command will
increase surveillance disruption and
seizures of drug shipments and provide
additional support for eradication
efforts which are going on right now
record pace we're deploying additional
Navy destroyers combat ships aircraft
and helicopters Coast Guard cutters and
air force surveillance aircraft doubling
our capabilities in the region very
importantly our forces are fully
equipped with personnel protective
equipment and we've taken additional
safety measures to ensure our troops
remain healthy secretary mark s /
Attorney General Bill Barr national
security adviser Robert O'Brien will
provide more details in addition I'm
going to have general Milley who's done
an incredible job so many ways say a few
words and also with us our Chief of
Naval Operations Admiral Gil day who you
know I think you know and Commandant of
the Coast Guard Admiral Schultz so I'm
going to ask mark to start and then we
can go and after that we're gonna take
questions as it pertains to this and
then we'll go on to phase 2 which is the
virus itself okay thank you please mark
well thank you mr. president and good
afternoon everyone I appreciate the
opportunity to be here today as we make
this very important announcement at a
time when the nation and the department
defense are focused on protecting the
American people from the spread of the
corona virus we also remain vigilant to
the many other threats our country faces
today at the president's direction the
department defense in close cooperation
with our interagency partners began
enhanced counter narcotics operations in
the eastern Pacific Ocean and the
Caribbean Sea this initiative is part of
the administration's whole-of-government
approach to combating the flow of
illicit drugs into the United States and
protecting the American people from
their scourge I want to thank all of our
partners in this effort to include the
United States Coast Guard the Department
of Homeland Security the Drug
Enforcement Agency the Department of
Justice and members of the intelligence
community for the tremendous support and
cooperation to get conduct these
enhanced operations the president has
directed the deployment of additional
ships aircraft and security forces to
the
State Southern Command area of
responsibility included in this forest
package our Navy destroyers and with
torille combat ships Coast Guard cutters
p8 patrol aircraft and elements of an
army security force assistance Brigade
these additional forces will nearly
double our capacity to conduct counter
narcotics operations in the region
additionally 22 partner nations have
joined us in this fight bring with them
a variety of intelligence and operations
capabilities needed to defeat these
criminal organizations last year alone
the United States southern commands
operations resulted in the seizure of
over 280 metric tons of drugs much of
which was designated for shipment to
America while this was an incredible
achievement there is much more work to
be done
transnational criminal organizations
continue to threaten our security by
smuggling cocaine fentanyl
methamphetamines and other narcotics
across our borders these drug
traffickers put our communities
communities at risk and destroy lives
every year tens of thousands of
Americans die from drug overdose and
thousands more suffer the harmful
effects of addiction furthermore corrupt
actors like the illegitimate Maduro
regime in Venezuela rely on the profits
derived from the sell narcotics to
maintain their oppressive hold on power
the Venezuelan people continue to suffer
tremendously due to Maduro as criminal
control over the country drug
traffickers are seizing on this
lawlessness by increasing their illicit
activities we must do more to prevent
these drugs from arriving at our shores
these enhanced counter narcotics
operations that are now underway will
further disrupt the flow of illicit
drugs to America deny our adversaries
the financial resources they depend on
and build the capacity of our partner
nations throughout the region I want to
thank President Trump for his leadership
and support to this critical mission
this is particularly important time for
this operation to begin as nations
around the world shift their focus
inward to deal with the corona virus
pandemic many criminal organizations are
attempting to capitalize on this crisis
the enhanced operations we are
announcing today will keep the pressure
on these criminal groups and protect the
American people from the devastation
caused by the flow of illegal drugs into
our country mr. president thank you
for your leadership as we begin this
important operation while the men and
women of the United States military work
hard here at home to fight the
coronavirus we continue to take action
around the world to defend our great
country thank you and I like to invite
general Milley Thank You secretary for
those words and Thank You mr. president
for your leadership and I want to
publicly thank have no Craig Fowler the
commander of a u.s. Southern Command out
of Miami for leading this operation
which is underway effective today and
also Admiral Gill day the Chief of Naval
Operations Admiral Schultz for their
contributions to this from their
services this thousands of sailors Coast
Guardsmen soldiers airmen Marines
involved in this operation we came upon
some intelligence some time ago that the
drug cartels as a result of KO vid 19
we're going to try to take advantage of
this situation and try to infiltrate
additional drugs in our country as we
know that 70,000 Americans die on an
average annual basis to drugs that's
unacceptable we're at war with kovat 19
we're at war with terrorists and we are
at war with the drug cartels as well
this is the United States military you
will not penetrate this country you will
not get past Jump Street you're not
gonna come in here and kill additional
Americans and we will marshal whatever
assets are required to prevent your
entry into this country to kill
Americans so right now the Navy has
marshaled additional gray all ships from
both Paycom and you come and for the
naval fleet at Norfolk and they are set
sail already and they are in the
Caribbean right now addition to that
there's 10 Coast Guard cutters and
there's special operations forces and
security force assistance brigades along
with Air Force reconnaissance aircraft
the bottom line is you're not going to
get through now is not the time to try
to penetrate the United States with
illegal drugs to kill Americans with the
United States military we will defend
our country regardless of the cost Thank
You mr. president
Thank You secretary
Thank You mr. president thanks for your
decisive leadership as we confront this
unprecedented challenge posed by Corona
coronavirus and I'd like to thank you
for your support for this important
initiative and thank all of the
Secretary of Defense and all the
services for taking on this this
important initiative obviously during
this crisis we're all focused above all
else on covin 19 but at the same time
our law enforcement and national
security work must go forward protecting
the American people from the full array
of threats for the Department of Justice
one of our highest priorities must
remain destroying the Mexican cartels
their trafficking is largely responsible
for the deaths as we all know now of
70,000 Americans a year and also the
cost of this don't count the destroyed
families the destroyed lives the
draining of our national treasure as
state budgets are crushed by the burden
that this the this narcotic trafficking
causes the president has made clear that
we are in this fight against the cartels
to win and that we are not interested in
half measures and that the threat posed
by the cartel is not just a
law-enforcement threat but a national
security threat as well and in December
building on your success with the
Mexican president in forging a
cooperative relationship in the area of
immigration you asked me to go down and
meet with the president Lopez Obrador
and our Mexican counterparts to see if
we could also establish a more
comprehensive and coordinated effort
with the Mexicans in confronting the
cartels and we've had some successful
visits and discussions and currently
have an array of activities underway
against the cartels and we anticipate
along with the Mexicans that these are
going to bear fruit in the
ahead but it quickly became clear that
we can obtain the most immediate results
the best bang for the buck
where we increase the assets involved in
interdiction on both the Pacific and
Atlantic side of Mexico and the Central
American countries for years the cartels
have been using these sea routes to take
the cocaine up from principally Colombia
now also at of Venezuela and these sea
routes on both coasts have become the
primary means of bringing cocaine up to
the United States because of the superb
work done by the Defense Department and
our intelligence community we know
exactly most of the time where these
traffickers are at sea but were
significantly have been up until now
significantly limited in our ability to
interdict because of the numbers of the
assets we have deployed prior today or
this limitation meant we could only
intercept the fraction of the
traffickers that we and the various
boats that were detected this will now
double our capacity and we are talking
about hundreds of tons of cocaine now
we're now in a position to seize so this
is going to radically improve our
interdiction efforts and put tremendous
pressure we think on the cartels and the
effort that SOUTHCOM is undertaking is
going to save lives by taking drugs off
the street last week I announced the
unsealing of charges of narco terrorism
drug trafficking and other crimes
against the former Maduro regime 16
members of that regime and their
involvement in trafficking of 250 metric
tons a year a lot of that comes by sea
as I discussed at that time but also
because of the pressure we're applying
by our sea interdiction they are trying
to establish an air route out of an
well up in to Central America which is
one of the reasons we're trying to move
firmly against that corrupt regime
you know this drug war has gone on for
many decades and at times in the past
we've had great success and great
results and at times we've taken our eye
off the ball
fortunately not in this administration
and I'm grateful that you mr. president
have brought focus to this fight and the
determination to use whatever tools are
necessary to win the fight the cartels
have to be defeated both for the people
of this country and for the people of
Mexico and Venezuela so I'd like to
thank you again mr. president secretary
Esper for providing the wherewithal
required to help win this war against
the cartels and others who seek to send
illicit drugs into our country and with
that I'd like to introduce ambassador
O'Brien Thank You general Thank You mr.
president
today's action is another example of the
bold leadership of President Trump and
his commitment to protecting the
homeland against threats that seek to
destabilize the United States and our
Western Hemisphere the uncontrolled flow
of illegal drugs into the United States
poisons our communities fuels the
dangerous epidemic epidemic of addiction
and threatens the safety and security of
all Americans
the impressive US Navy Coast Guard Army
Marine Corps Air Force and interagency
operation will address a range of
threats to our national security posed
by narco traffickers and narco
terrorists it will reduce illicit
financial support for the drug traffic
for drug trafficking that provides the
corrupt madero regime in Venezuela and
other bad actors with the funds
necessary to conduct their malign
activities under president Trump's
leadership we will continue to execute
our maximum pressure policy to counter
the Madero regime's malign activities
including drug trafficking and that this
operation will help to choke off the
funds that go to that corrupt regime
madero narco terrorists and criminals
should make no mistake that even as we
are working around the clock to fight
the spread of hantavirus we will
continue to execute the
residents counter-narcotics strategy
we're working on a number of important
national security priorities as we face
this public health crisis the United
States will continue to combat
disinformation and fake news about this
virus we will work with the world's
largest oil producers to address
volatility in global oil markets we will
always protect our servicemen and
servicewomen around the world including
in Iraq and Afghanistan
I want the American people to know that
President Trump and vice president Pence
and their administration are working
tirelessly every day to protect the
health and well-being of Americans and
respond to the coronavirus our
adversaries should take note however
this president has a clear-eyed focus on
America's national security as security
interest and let me be clear it would be
a mistake a mistake with terrible
consequences for any adversary to
attempt to do us harm during this health
crisis or ever for that matter thank you
very much Thank You mr. president
so question is for you mr. president or
secretary Esper what has changed that is
allowing these assets to be deployed now
whereas general Barr said in the past
they were not available well for a long
time we've had a lot of drugs coming
into our country and it's not that it's
increased its we've probably got it down
a little bit but it's still a tremendous
number and families are being ruined
lives are being ruined it's an
incredible thing especially as you're at
this position you would never believe it
I see things that nobody would believe I
see reports that nobody would believe so
I met with the group behind me all of
them and we said what do you think we
can do and I think they can introduce
their we can stop it before it gets to
the shores and they're coming from all
over the place and we have incredibly
talented people so I think I'm gonna let
mark just give them a little bit of an
answer to that but we just want to see
if we can stop a big a good percentage
of the drugs coming into our country
sure thing thanks mr. president so first
of all it's simply a matter of
prioritization the president's giving us
very
got some what's important to him and
protecting the American people and as
some of you know I've begun I began a
review months ago looking at all of our
different geographic combatant commands
and looking at where we can free up time
money and and resources to put in into
other endeavors in this case we had
scrutinized our inventory fairly closely
that chairman milli did a great deal of
work on this with with admiral gil de
and we felt that there was no risk to
the fleet to our operations to free up
in this case naval ships we also freed
up aircraft and other assets to apply
them to this presidential priority and
of course the Coast Guard did the same
so it was a very good operation we feel
this is very important to the American
people and completely in line with the
president's direction in how long will
you be able to keep up this operational
tempo well it depends what we're going
to do is we're gonna run it for some
matter of time I'm not gonna disclose
how long it will be and then we will
assess it and then we'll make
adjustments from there we may increase
we may decrease we may sustain as is but
this will be an assessment we will do as
an interagency team we will report back
to the president and we'll take further
guidance from there but it'll also have
an impact on the virus because we have
people trying to get in so not only
drugs but then we have a new phenomena
and that's at least for the next
hopefully short period of time the virus
so we'll be able to have an effect on
that to fish a little bit because you
tie it to Cove in nineteen saying that
these drug cartels we're taking
advantage of the situation you have this
pandemic how exactly well because we're
focused on so many other parts of the
country and even parts of the world and
all of a sudden areas where we we had it
clamped down pretty tight
well furnace you know the wall is up to
about a hundred and sixty miles already
and any areas where we have that wall
for the most part contiguous we have
fill-ins
but we're up to one hundred and sixty
one miles exactly and any place where
you have that wall other than walking
around it on the edges it's stopping
everybody cold and we're stopping when
nobody's seen anything like if that's
how good it works and the other side
knew it worked that well everybody
because everybody was forward five years
ago all of a sudden they changed it's
having a tremendous impact but we are
now focused on so many different
things because of what's happened
because of this horrible I say it's a
horrible phenomena that now we've got to
focus on drugs and the drugs come in
from different methods and we have the
best people that see anywhere in the
world so we'll have a tremendous impact
on drugs but one of the other things
will also have an impact we think on the
on the virus ambassador O'Brien did
China under report both the number of
cases and the death toll from the corona
virus and if that's the case mr.
president what does that mean for our
relationship with China and your
relationship with President Xi well
number one I think the president has a
great relationship with President Xi and
we'd like to have a great relationship
with China unfortunately we're just not
in a position to confirm any of the
numbers that are coming out of China
there's no way to confirm any of those
numbers there's lots of public reporting
on whether the numbers are are too low
you've got access to those reports that
are coming out of Chinese social media
and and some of the few reporters that
left in China we just have no way to
confirm any of those numbers reported
however they report but we had a great
call the other night we're working
together on a lot of different things
including trade they're buying a lot
they're spending a lot of money they're
giving it to our farmers they're paying
our farmers for the product so you know
we're gonna we're gonna continue that
along John you I have another was sorry
you tweeted earlier today that there was
you have uncovered intelligence that
there is a sneak attacks being planned
against American troops American assets
in Iraq are we talking about Thai but
Hezbollah again also were said but we
just have information that they were
planning something and it's very good
information it was led by Iran not
necessarily Iran but by groups supported
by Iran but that to me is Iran and we're
just saying don't do it don't do it yes
but be a very bad thing for them if they
did it last time they did do it in early
March cap Taji there was a response from
the military again
type Hezbollah and type Hezbollah alone
you have a very powerful response by the
way that response knocked out five
different places but it also took out a
lot of very bad people just though that
if it happens again it may go up the
future well that was a very big response
you know we knocked out a lot we looked
they hit one said we had five big ones
and ammunition sights you saw that you
saw what happened and I won't say how
many people were killed but some bad
people were killed and a lot of them
that was a big response but this
response will be bigger if they do
something yeah yes Thank You mr.
president
just going back to your conversation
with president jean wondering if you
received an intelligence report they
talked about the discrepancy in the
numbers and if you address that with we
have not received that but their numbers
seemed to be a little bit on the light
side and I'm being nice when I say that
relative to what we witnessed and what
was reported but we discussed that with
him not so much the numbers as what they
did and how they're doing and we're in
constant communication with I mean I
would say the biggest communication is
myself and President Xi the
relationships very good we have look
they're spending they will be spending
when things even out this is obviously a
little bit of a hurdle what's happened
over the last month but they'll be
spending two hundred and fifty billion
dollars buying our product fifty billion
dollars to the farmers alone
two hundred billion dollars two other
things they never did that before so we
have a great trade deal and we'd like to
keep it they'd like to keep it then the
relationship is good as to whether or
not their numbers are accurate I'm not
an accountant from China many things at
all in terms of the trade deal no
because people just don't know people
don't know where did it come from
I think we all understand where it came
from and President Xi understands said
we don't have to make a big deal out of
it we didn't like the fact that they
said it came from our soldiers and they
haven't pursued that it was and that was
a mid-level person said that that was
not a high-level person so I assume I
will always assume the best
assume the high level people didn't know
about it it was a foolish statement so
look the relationship with China is a
good one and my relationship with him is
really good Chinese propaganda that you
mentioned as well as ambassador O'Brien
so in the past several weeks China has
been shipping
ppes you know mass they're either been
selling or donating everywhere Africa
Europe Italy Russia and really pushing
this narrative that they're taking on a
global leadership role in the crisis so
what are your thoughts on that and is
there any final binders they want that
is a positive if they're helping other
countries we have 151 countries right
now that are under siege by the virus
under siege so we're doing really badly
you know they don't know about social
distancing these are countries that
aren't highly sophisticated they don't
have great communication to the rest of
the world I mean they don't know the
things that we're doing and that some
others are able to do and if China can
help them I'm all for it I'm for all of
us helping everybody we're soon gonna
have more ventilators that we need we're
building thousands of ventilators right
now and now it takes a period of time to
build them and again nobody could have
known a thing like this could happen
we're building thousands we will fairly
soon be at a point where we have far
more than we can use
even after we stockpile for some future
catastrophe which we hope doesn't happen
we're gonna be distributing them the
extras around the world we'll go to
Italy we'll go to France we'll go to
Spain which is an you know very hard hit
shipment of USAID stockpiles of BP's
abroad no no truth whatsoever you're we
want
I would love China and other countries
if they have additional supplies medical
supplies to give to other countries 150
150 why would I stop that wouldn't it be
terrible to stop it the u.s. stopped a
shipment of our own stock through USAID
other countries you know whatever we
have whatever we've committed to we
commit but we also need a lot for
ourselves so we're very focused on that
until we get over this so obviously
we're not going to be shipping too much
until now we do have excess of certain
things and we don't have enough of
others I just had a great talk today
with the Doug McMillon from Walmart and
I gave him a very very big order to her
gowns for protective gear for the
doctors for the nurses for everything
and he's actually very excited about it
he's the biggest purchaser of this kind
of thing I mean of of anything probably
in the world and he is very excited
about it and he said what size I said
it's almost an unlimited when you look
at these hospitals the amount that they
order you almost say how could they
possibly use so much whether it's masks
or the protective gear but we are
supplying a tremendous amount and we
just ordered a lot from Walmart and he's
taking this one personally and I said
let it go ship let it be ship not to a
warehouse directly to the side of the
hospital or wherever they need it
because we save a lot of time when we do
that so Walmart in addition to many
other companies and people is now
involved at the highest level but we
don't want to lose ground that's why
we're doing it I don't want to lose
ground
it's a big fight I've seen many families
where they wiped out because they lost a
son or a daughter or a husband or a wife
or whatever or all of them and we don't
want to lose ground and we are heavily
focused on the virus very heavily
focused and with this we have never
after this goes into effect which
essentially is now we will never have
been so focused on drugs coming into our
country as we are right now and remember
as that wall gets bigger that really
helps us a lot really helps us a lot
yeah please Mexican government
latin-american government working in
conjunction with this operation to help
with that project many of the
government's are in Mexico in particular
is in Mexico right now is we have 27,000
Mexican soldiers on our southern border
keeping people out of our country and
we're very few people are coming into
our country right now and as we complete
again the wall in addition to the 27,000
soldiers it's it's a very it's a very
tough place to come into when I when I
took over people were coming in and they
were bringing whatever they wanted they
were bringing drugs of any type and now
it's very hard for them and it will get
harder and harder but the President of
Mexico is a great guy who's really
helped us a lot
27,000 soldier 27,000 Mexican soldiers
and you remember when I first took over
they had all of the caravans coming up
with 10,000 15,000 people in the
caravans they were marching through
Mexico that's not happening anymore
please Allah or the magine do you know
if they're working in conjunction with
the Mexican cartels is there any
intelligence indicating that I cannot
tell you that I can I know the answer to
that I believe I do but I cannot tell
you that we have information that would
lead us to believe something very
powerfully but I cannot tell you the
educator please mr. president hello US
forces in Iraq taking any precautions
this particular attack and have you
there taken precautions and we are
watching it very closely and if
something bad happens it's going to be
very painful for the other side been in
touch with the Iraqi government about
this they know about it but you know
we're down to a small force now over the
years since I got we've been bringing
smaller and smaller and we're done right
now to a small number but we have very
powerful airpower there we have the big
base and
which will you know I mean nobody can
get near it and nobody can even get near
that but we've really largely left you
know we've taken tremendous amounts out
and we've deployed them elsewhere
including bringing some back home do you
think tweeting about it well it's social
media it gets out I have you know
hundreds of millions of people number
one on Facebook did you know I was
number one of Facebook Annie I just
found out I'm number one on Facebook I
thought that was very nice for whatever
it means no it represents something and
when I can explain to people just don't
do it you know it's gonna be bad if you
do it's gonna be really bad and they
don't need to do it they have enough
problems
Iran has enough problems without doing
that but we've been pulling back for
substantially over the last year in Iraq
and so you know that's the way it is
before you don't want to give the enemy
whoever that is in this case a heads up
do you feel like maybe you did no I'm
just giving them a warning it's not a
heads up I'm giving them a warning
there's a big difference
I'm saying if you do anything to hurt
our troops they're gonna they're gonna
pay a price now they did last time you
know as per the question they did last
time we didn't make a big deal out of it
but we hit very very hard five massive
major ammunition sites and a lot of
people went with it a lot of bad people
a lot of enemy went with it and we
didn't want to make a big deal out of it
but they paid a big price they'll pay a
much bigger price this time if they do
anything Gildea here perhaps we can ask
a question about what the plans are for
the Roosevelts or in terms of Roosevelt
we're making great progress in terms of
testing and also moving moving people
off the ship so in the past day or so
we've moved over a thousand that number
will increase to more than 2,700 by
Friday as we continue to increase the
testing as well and fly those samples
off so again after pretty pretty quickly
well the should remain fully operational
it is fully operational now
and will remain so to remain so what
protocols are you putting in place to
help mitigate the spread of Parana virus
among servicemen and women at the fork
across the fleet before we have any
ships getting underway for training
exercises for deployments they're
spending for those sailors are spending
14 days in quarantine before they get
underway we've increased the amount of
testing equipment as well as physicians
and board ships at sea
so we've taken additional steps since
the beginning of the various ports
anymore all right I think we correct we
probably have decided on that civilians
what I had wires I'd like to have one
thing to that there seems to be this
narrative out there that we should just
shut down the entire United States
military and address the problem that
way that's not feasible we have a
mission our mission is to protect the
United States of America and our people
and so we live and working in cramped
quarters whether it's a an aircraft
carrier a submarine a tank a bomber it's
the nature of our business but the chain
of command has very clear guidance and
I'm confident between the commanding
officers and the senior non-commissioned
officers there they're taken every
reasonable precaution to make sure we
practice as best we can social
distancing sanitizing environments etc
consistent with that mission and that's
what I trust admiral gil de acting
secretary MOLLE and all the other
service chiefs and service leaders to do
and I'm confident we'll do that because
keep in mind we have a job to do and we
will continue to do it defend the United
States of America
mr. president you mentioned the
stockpile earlier the Washington Post
reported today that the u.s. stockpile
is nearly depleted because we're sending
it directly to hospitals we don't want
it to come to the stockpile because then
we have to take it after it arrives and
bring it to various states and hospitals
one of the things and again we ask the
states to do this as much as possible
many of the states have people that
whether it's that or clothing they make
clothing lots of clothing in many of the
different states we said see if you can
get it directly from those manufacturers
make a deal
we'll use the purchase act if we have to
on them they won't go by the way so many
people are the spirit is incredible what
they're doing but we've asked states
where they have large manufacturers of
different types of equipment to use
those local factories as local plants
and have it made directly ship it right
into the hospitals we're shipping things
right and we have as you know almost
10,000 ventilators which we need for
flexibility it's a lot it sounds like a
lot but it's not because as you see on
the board from yesterday as this scourge
as this plague as this virus moves it
moves very fast and we don't know yet
whether we're gonna need it in Louisiana
in New York and we'd you know wherever
it may be so we're ready for it we're
totally ready for it we're gonna be
shipping out we've already agreed to
ship out over a thousand today to
different sites different locations but
we have to have the flexibility of
moving the ventilators to where to where
the virus is going and we'll be able to
see that you know we'll be able to see
that from charts a couple of days in
advance so right now we have a nice pile
of ventilators we have a lot more coming
in we have a lot of I think we have 11
companies making ventilators right now
very good companies and they're making
them you know about Ford you know about
General Motors but we have a lot of
companies making the ventilators right
now so now the question is you know when
you make one it doesn't get made in 15
minutes it's not a mask can go quickly
a ventilator takes time to build it's
very very as we discussed it's complex
it's big gets expensive you know etc but
we'll be able to move we have great
flexibility John I was just going to say
sir if you want to move on to slowly
coronavirus or stick with yeah I think
if does anybody have any other questions
for this great group of brilliant people
yes please
is the military personnel that's been
fanned out across the country to help
combat the virus is there any chance
that they're planning to see at some
point halfway military personnel tree or
cv90 patients well excuse me as you know
we have the hospital ships currently
deployed one in LA and one in New York
City so they are they will be they could
be treating patients as they come in
we're taking precautionary measures to
screen them beforehand to make sure that
they're not they're not exposed if you
will same with the military hospitals
that we are we are deploying certainly
again to New York Seattle and other
places but the one thing we got to be
careful of where we were is that these
are deployable assets they are unique so
if we want to retain the ability to
deploy military doctors expeditionary
military hospitals around the country
we've got to preserve and protect them
as best we can that said we remain
completely available to assist as need
be as directed by FEMA as as the vice
president and the president asks us
that's what we commit to do to the
American people to help safeguard them
and protect them through this do this
virus so as part of that they will may
be seeing
Myers patients are they strictly be
seeing other patients and helping they
could have called upon I think the best
use for them is based on their training
and how they're structured and organized
is for trauma we can take the load off
of hospitals with regard to their trauma
patients thereby freeing up rooms and
other doctors particularly dr. x' who
are you know respiratory nurses or
doctors who deal with infectious disease
to treat those type of patients so I
think it's the best use of our resources
but again if push comes to shove we're
prepared to do what we have to to to
assist the American people at the same
time preserving the Medicaid medical
capability we need to support our
operation deployed forces abroad brand
new hospital ships because these ships
have really I mean they really struck a
blow very positive blow for what they're
doing going here Los Angeles going into
New York so we're looking very seriously
at building two additional ships of
about the same size
it'll either be bit well building but
we're looking at building either two new
ones were doing the renovation of
another lordship but this has really
worked out well so probably two
brand-new ones you want them you don't
want them to get back to work and
capture all those bad people follow up
mr. president
Orpah mr. secretary I know that
secretary Wilkie has said he's on
standby waiting to hear if the hospitals
need to be opened the door need to be
open to civilians are you talking about
that should we see that happen happens
in our schools yeah certain can move
very quickly he's a very capable man
we're ready to move very quickly as an
example in Louisiana they have a very
big Hospital so we're looking to move
very quickly if we need them you know
hopefully we won't need them we're gonna
find out pretty soon we're only gonna
know when at the time it happens we
prepare for the worst we are preparing
for the worst
unfortunately that's the way we have to
look at it eating time out patience and
I'm just curious what about things like
you know giving birth what mothers be
expected they're not doing that on the
ship that's the one thing they're not
doing outside of the cove at 19 they're
not doing that the birth of a baby not
being done on the ships okay can I have
a follow-up question with Attorney
General Authorities this this has to do
with the visa restrictions for
immigrants process the administration
considering easing the restrictions were
waiving restrictions for adopters with
j1 or H
Jesus so they can help other doctors
during this crisis actually the
immigration laws are no longer under the
administration of the Department of
Justice and I haven't been participating
any of those discussions wh now this is
on the topic of coronavirus in Iran the
w-h-o confirms that iran is vastly under
reporting its coronavirus cases not just
cases but fatalities according to
on-the-ground estimates that it might be
as high as fifteen and a half thousand
deaths thirty-two commanders in the
military in Iran are now confirmed
either in dire condition or dead you
have 8% of the parliament now down with
current - so is Iran's soundings of
aggressions today that president Trump
just tweeted about do you think
strategically is that a bluff on their
part or is this a sign of very clear
desperation where are you strategically
on that well first and foremost we
empathize for the Iranian people I mean
they clearly have been hit hard as you
know I think the president spoken about
it certainly secretary Pompeo we've
offered assistance we've offered medical
supplies etc they have refused that I
think if the Iranian regime put more
interest in terms of taking care of
their people and in in the context of
this virus they would be better served
instead the Iranian regime continues to
want to spread its malign activities
throughout the region they want to
continue to send out the Kurds force and
others to to cause problems throughout
the region we know that in one way shape
or form they are the resourcing
directing approving of whatever
operations for Shia militia groups in
Iraq that are targeting American forces
so I think at the end of the day again I
feel deep concern for the Iranian people
it what the important thing is that the
Iranian government should focus on them
and stop this malign behavior that
they've been conducting now for over 40
years
I think the entire region and certainly
the Iranian people would be better off
for it
and I happen to think they want to make
a deal they just don't know really how
to start and they've been giving some
bad advice by former secretary Kerry
it's a very bad advice and I really
think they want to make a deal which is
the Logan Act but would have to look at
the Logan Act what you have to do is
take a look I think they've been given
very bad advice by secretary Kerry I
think that I think they're dying to make
a deal look their country's in trouble
their economics are shot there and
they've got a lot of bad things going I
think they'd like to make a deal they
can get it settled very quickly no
nuclear weapons no weapons they can't
have nuclear weapons it's very simple
okay let's let these folks get back to
work is that okay thank you all very
much
so as we deploy our servicemembers to
combat both threats abroad invisible
enemy at home earlier today I spoke to
our nation's incredible warriors and
military families spent a long time on
the phone with thousands and thousands
of families that were hooked in in order
to stop the spread of the virus some of
these families have delayed planned
moves to their next duty station and in
other cases military families are also
waiting longer to welcome home the
heroes from deployment there's a
tremendous burden to bear and the
families have been involved with us for
so long and they are incredible without
the families they couldn't be the great
service members that they turned out to
be and they understand that and I must
say protecting our military families is
our top priority so they understand what
their what's happening with respect to
the virus and they understand it well
they've been fantastic as commander in
chief I'm deeply grateful for our
service members their spouses and their
children whose love devotion and
sacrifice keeps America strong to make
procure and deliver a crucial medical
supplies to our doctors nurses and
healthcare workers my administration is
leveraging the might of American
manufacturing supply chains and
innovators across the industry and of
course every industry and I just told
you about Walmart and I could tell you
about many more Hanes is making
protective gear and masks and we're
making tremendous amounts of product
there's never been anything like it at
the same time I tell the governor's get
it yourself if you can from your local
companies and your local warehouses and
factories if you can do that you should
do that because of the actions that
we've taken under the defense production
act manufacturers and suppliers are
sharing with FEMA and HHS their planned
orders and allocations to States and to
hospitals all over the region this
enables FEMA and HHS to work closely
with States local governments and
private sector to Alec
eight critical resources to highly
impacted areas working together we're
entirely focused on getting materials to
the right place at the right time so we
wanted to go directly to a hospital or
directly to a certain state location and
ideally not even hit the states
warehouses if we can avoid the
warehouses it's even better because they
go directly into a hospital and one
example of that is Ohio the great state
of Ohio senator Rob Portman called today
and he asked for some help and got us
did a tremendous job along with Mike
DeWine the great governor of Ohio to
facilitate a donation of 2.2 million
gowns 2.2 million Yuans think of what
that is 2.2 million - the strategic
national stockpile from Ohio based
Cardinal Health Cardinal Health we
appreciate it and they're making much
more than that and different types of
things
we're profoundly grateful for their
contribution to protect the lives and
safety of our healthcare professionals
Cardinals been working with us very well
FEMA and HHS formed a historic
partnership with the private sector
called project air bridge to bring
supplies from other countries to the
United States including gloves gowns
goggles and masks these supplies will
soon be distributed around the country
we have large cargo planes coming in
from various parts of the world every
day new plane loads are landing in
cities such as New York Miami Chicago
Los Angeles additional flights have been
scheduled and we're adding more and more
and they're actually coming in ahead of
schedule a lot of these flights are
coming in with a lot of material ahead
of schedule the amount of usage the
amount of need is something that
nobody's ever seen before we are getting
so much but no matter how much we get
they seem to use it up very quickly
more than 17,000 National Guard
personnel have now been activated all
across our country on Tuesday the vice
president sent a letter to the
governor's calling on them to have
lands in place to use the National Guard
to move medical supplies from warehouses
to hospitals so a lot of times we'll
deliver supplies to a warehouse in a
state someplace in New York or in New
Jersey or in Connecticut or wherever it
may be and they're having difficulty
getting it move so what we're doing if
we don't bring it directly to the
hospital is we've authorized it was a
special authorization the National Guard
to go into that facility and to move it
for the state so the the National Guard
is moving a lot of this equipment and
medical supplies into a hospital or into
an area where it's needed by the state
as I said yesterday difficult days are
ahead for our nation we're going to have
a couple of weeks starting pretty much
now but especially a few days from now
that are going to be horrific but even
in the most challenging of times
Americans do not despair we do not give
in to fear we pull together we persevere
and we overcome and we win this week
every American heart is joined with the
people of New York as they continue to
bear the brunt of the pandemic to every
New Yorker please know that we are by
your side I Love New York and every day
we will be with you and it could very
well be that others take over from New
York there are some areas some hotspots
in other states that are really
exploding some like Louisiana were very
late and then all of a sudden it was
like an explosion in confronting this
deadly plague America is armed with
capabilities never dreamed of in past
centuries you look at 1917 the pandemic
it was something ravaged parts of this
country but ravaged Europe ravaged they
say seventy-five to a hundred million
some people say 50 to 75 million people
died think of that and that was a long
time ago over a hundred years ago
very very many books written about the
1917 1918 pandemic our doctors are
poring over the virus genetic code
designing potential therapies and
vaccines our planes are airlifting
supplies from every corner of the earth
we're watching other countries and
they're watching us to see whether or
not and who's gonna be the first to come
up with a cure or a remedy of some kind
or even a help if it can help and of
course a vaccine we're looking very
strongly for a vaccine Johnson & Johnson
is doing well and other companies are
doing very well but our most powerful
asset our greatest weapon in this effort
is the spirit of our people and we want
to keep away keep a distance keep away
if you don't get it it solves a lot of
problems if you don't get it and you
can't get it if you keep the distance
American spirit is unyielding unwavering
and unbreakable it's incredible I've
never seen anything like it the way the
way the people are pulled together the
unity of this country so together we're
going to win this war and the sooner we
do the sooner we can begin to rebuild
and we're ready to rebound and return to
normal lives we work for the best
economy in the history of the world the
best economy that this country has ever
seen the best employment numbers we've
ever had 160 million people working
almost 160 million to a point where the
professionals came to me and they say
sir you're gonna have to shut the
country down I said what does that mean
they said so you're gonna have to shut
it down and we're gonna build it up and
I think we're gonna build it up fast I
think we're gonna have a tremendous
rebound there's a great energy and a
great pent-up demand and as you know
phase 3 was terrific and phase 4 what
passed in Congress and phase 4 if that
happens will be great I already proposed
a paying almost zero interest on bonds
and I proposed a two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan which would not only
fix our roads and highways and bridges
and tunnels and other things but will
also do something very good it's called
the jobs I'm also asking that
restaurants and entertainment facilities
go back to the old deductibility from
corporations where corporations can buy
because otherwise a lot of these
restaurants are gonna have a hard time
reopen and it takes a long time and
they're gonna have a hard time reopening
so we're asking for going back to
deductibility where corporations can buy
and corporations can go out to lunch and
they pay and they get a deduction what
they eat they get a deduction on the
bill and same with the entertainment
it's going to bring a lot of people back
I think it will open up the restaurant
business people forget that years ago
they had that and when they got rid of
it when they ended it for whatever
reason but they ended it many many
restaurants went out of business many
entertainment type facilities went out
of business and now's a great time to
bring it back it was it was a terrible
time for that business after they ended
it but this is a great time to bring it
back it'll keep our restaurants going in
fact I think the restaurant business
will be actually bigger and better than
it is right now so we're also talking
about that and now what we'll do is
we'll take some questions and I see Mike
is back with some of the folks that's
great dr. pouchy and we will Thank You
Debra so we'll take some questions and
we make progress day by day please
yesterday you were talking about a
friend you had who is in a call
I'm starting to hear your friends going
through that but you said this is no flu
there's still some people who kind of
think of this as a flu and over the past
month you've compared it to the flu
sometimes saying treat it like the flu
or you know what treated pale we handle
the flu so what changed your thinking on
that severity I think also and looking
at the way the contagion it is so
contagious nobody's ever seen anything
like this where large groups of people
all of a sudden just by being in the
presence of somebody having the flu has
never been like that and there is a flu
is contagious but nothing like we've
ever seen here also the violence of it
if if it hits the right person and you
know what those stats are if it hits the
right person that person is in deep
trouble and my friend was the right
person when you heard about that with
your friend like was that a turning
point well I'm not anybody know before
that I knew how because I'm seeing
numbers that I'm seeing statistics that
are you know not exactly very good so
but but it hit him very hard
he's strong a very strong kind of a guy
but he's older he's heavier and he's
sort of central casting for what we're
talking about and it hit him very hard
I've never seen anything like it yeah
mr. president and maybe this question is
well for dr. Burks or dr. Falchi Senator
Lindsey Graham tweeted last night we
checked today that there are still
flights that are running between hot
spots like New York and Detroit New
Orleans as well a number of flights were
completed today Senator Graham's point
is if you're going to declare mitigation
should it not be full mitigation and you
stop people from travel we're thinking
about doing that at the same time we
just you know to start these airlines
and to start this whole thing over again
is very tough John it's very tough and
you have them going in some cases from
hot spot to hot spot if you notice
they're usually hot spot to hot spot
very few flights New York to Miami
and but we're we're thinking it we're
certainly looking at it but once you do
that you really are you really are
clamping down an industry that was
desperately needed calculation as to
whether or not you you keep the Indo
we're going or your risk spreading to
change that is a calculation that we're
looking at right now we're looking at it
very strongly please
so let me follow up to that mr.
president not every governor has issued
a stay at home order all of you have
made it very clear how important it is
to stay home that we are in a dire
situation here and that's how you stop
the spread it's staying home why not
take the power out of the hands of the
governor's and you just issue a stay at
home order four states are different and
I understand that governor of Florida
great governor Ron de santis issued one
today and that's good that's great but
there are some states that are different
there are some states that don't have
much of a problem there is so well they
don't have the problem they don't have
thousands of people that are positive
with thousands of people that even think
they might have it or hundreds of people
in some cases so you have to look you
have to look at states you have to give
a little bit of flexibility but every
state in the Midwest or if Alaska has an
example doesn't have a problem it's
awfully tough to say close it down so we
have to have a little bit of flexibility
look we're helping governors we're
really here to help governor's they're
the front line of attack and that
includes in purchasing by the way we're
here and we're backing them up and
there's never been a backup like we've
given them we're giving them billions of
dollars worth of things medical supplies
and ventilators thousands and thousands
of ventilators we have thousands under
construction right now we have thousands
ready to go in case they need it's never
been anything like this I mean we've
they've done really the people have done
incredibly we're building hospitals all
over the country we're building
hospitals right now at a rate that has
never even been contemplated before
they're mobile hospitals but they're
really not mobile I mean they're
incredible structure
but we're building many hospitals
Louisiana New Jersey New York we just
finished a massive hospital complex and
we also have medical centers built in
New York we're building hospitals at the
rate that this country has never done
before and hopefully it's all gonna work
out this mr. president just want to make
sure we're clear on the plains are you
looking at just curtailing routes
between certain hot spots or is it
broadly well we're looking at the whole
thing because we're getting into a
position now where we want to do that we
have to do that and so we'll look at it
the whole thing second question on
economics just with oil oil prices are
very low the saudis of increased
production I know - spoken about liking
low oil prices but then there's also the
industry aspect from 1950 these oil
prices and that's when they had big
dollars big beautiful dollars for you do
you advocate cuts do you advocate cuts
to production to you well look we have a
great oil industry and the oil industry
is being ravaged and as you know Russia
and I spoke to President Putin we had a
great call Russia Saudi Arabia I spoke
with a crown prince we had a great call
but I think that they will work it out
over the next few days if you ask me I
think it's just it's too simple not to
be able to they both know what they have
to do so I think I have confidence in
both that they'll be able to work it out
but it's it has ravaged an industry
worldwide that here I mean worldwide the
oil industry has been ravaged so there
was a lot of oil production to start off
with and then on top of it it got hit
with the virus and business went down 35
40 % so that that business is a tough
one and you know they have ships all
over the sea I told you yesterday all
over to see massive tankers that they're
using for storage they go out and they
just sit there there's no place to go
they have massive amounts now gasoline
is going to be 99 cents a gallon unless
you know that that's already started
it's popping up $0.99 so that's like
giving a massive tax cut through people
of our country when we try and get the
airlines going if if fuel is costing
much less it helps with getting the
airlines which is always a tough
business always has been a tough
business but with that being said look
I'm I want to get that industry back
where was we were doing records in that
industry also we want to get it back to
where it was so I think that Saudi
Arabia Russia they're negotiating
they're talking and I think they'll come
up with something I'm gonna meet with
the oil companies on Friday I'm gonna
meet with independent oil producers also
on Friday or Saturday maybe Sunday but
we're having a lot of meetings on it I
think I know what to do to solve it but
if if they were unable to solve it
then I think I know what to do - so now
but it's it's tough I think I know what
to do to solve it we don't want to lose
our great oil companies you know with a
number-one producer of oil in the world
and a month ago when you said that it
was great today when you say it it's not
so meaningful but I do believe there's a
way that that can be solved or pretty
well solved and I'd rather not do that I
think that Russia and Saudi Arabia at
some point are going to make a deal in
the not-too-distant future because it's
very bad for Russia it's very bad for
Saudi Arabia that's very bad I mean it's
bad for both so I think they're gonna
make a deal you know the food market is
a wonderful thing it's amazing how it
can work but I think they're gonna make
a deal yeah mr. president a couple of
questions one for you one for mr. wolf
as possible over five million immigrants
in this country do
taxes through their ID numbers yet they
will not receive any money in their
stimulus package and no undocumented
immigrant who received any aid from the
government during this crisis how do you
suppose they survive during the culprit
nineteen well you know you're seeing
undocumented meaning they came in
illegally and a lot of people would say
we have a lot of citizens right now that
won't be working so what are you gonna
do it's a tough thing it's a very
terrible it's a very sad question I must
be honest with you but they came in
illegally and we have a lot of people
that are citizens of our country that
won't be able to have jobs now I do
think once we get rid of the virus I
think we're gonna have a boom economy I
think it's gonna go up rather quickly
maybe very quickly and maybe slowly but
it's gonna go up and it'll all come back
and I think it's actually going to come
back stronger than what it was because
of the stimulus but it's it's a really
sad situation and we are working on it
I will tell you I'm not gonna give you a
hard and fast answer because I just want
to tell you it's something I think about
and it's something we're working on
looking beyond the were on the other
side of this curve are we looking at
living with some sort of social
distancing guidelines especially it
essentially until there's treatment or a
vaccine for example people looking
forward to the summer talk about you
know going to baseball games going to
concerts we have political conventions
over the summer are things like that
possible or safe without a vaccine or
treatment ways yeah I think if we get to
the part of the curve that dr. Burke
showed yesterday when it goes down to
essentially no new cases no deaths at a
period of time I think it makes sense
that you're gonna have to relax social
distancing the one thing we hopefully
would have in place and I believe we
will have in place there's a much more
robust system to be able to identify
someone who's infected isolate them and
then do contact tracing because if you
have a really good program of
containment that prevents you from ever
having to get into mitigation we're in
mitigation right now that's what the
social and physical distancing is the
ultimate the ultimate solution to a
virus that might keep coming back would
be a vaccine in fact I was on the weekly
conference call with the whu-oh
sponsored group of all the health
leaders in the world who are dealing
with this and we all came to the
agreement that we may have cycling with
another season will be much better
prepared we likely will have
interventions but the ultimate game
changer in this will be a vaccine the
same way a vaccine for other diseases
that were scourge us in the past that
now we don't even worry about I mean the
vaccine is is as I said it's on target
we're still in Phase one there were
three doses that we had a test we've
been through the first two doses we're
on the highest dose now when we get that
data it'll take a few months to get the
data to we don't feel confident to go to
the phase two and then a few months from
now we'll be in phase two and I think
we're right on target for the year to a
year and a half you and dr. Burks have
either of you received threats of any
kind or have you been given a security
detail given you've been out here every
day on camera speaking well I mean I
anything that has to do with security
detail I'd have to have you refer that
question to the Inspector General of HHS
rather than my answer that
big trouble a favorite tech you know
he was a great basketball player did
anybody know he was a little on the
short side for the NBA but he was
talented he he won a game I read the sir
he won a game that was unwinnable
against a great team and his whole team
said we can't beat this team and he went
in they won the game right that was a
couple of years ago for a few years ago
the head never changes the attitude
never changes I don't want to hit you
with everything that's coming along but
a lot of people who are watching
television today heard from a researcher
named dr. Jacob Granville who's come up
with a potential antibody therapy that
he has given to you Sam red just wanting
to know if you know anything about this
well you might be able to tell people at
home about it you've seen it you know
Jonah I don't know specifically this
individual what they're doing but I can
tell you there's a lot of activity that
is centered around a passive transfer of
antibodies in the form of convalescent
plasma one the number is to get immune
globulin that you precipitate out of the
plasma and another is monoclonal
antibody it's based on the same
principle of a few have a protective
antibody passive transfer of that could
provide not only protection
prophylactically but also treatment this
is an old concept in fact immunology was
born decades and decades and decades ago
with the concept of giving passive
transfer a serum to an individual to
protect them from an infection so it's I
wouldn't be surprised if he and a number
of other people are pursuing this it's
the right thing to do at what point can
we as
country expect there to be a widespread
antibody testing so we know exactly what
we're dealing with here as well as other
questions such as you know when can
people who are deemed to be healthy
donate blood for example okay so when
you talk about anybody testing there are
a couple of things that you want to do
you want to find out if someone has been
infected and whether or not they're
gonna ultimately wind up being protected
anybody testing right now is not the
first thing on our priority it's
something that we need to do is testing
to see if someone is infected it is very
important ultimately to be able to get a
feel for what the penetrance of the
infection was in society for a number of
reasons you get a better feel of what
the impact has been but also you get a
better feel of what the herd immunity
would be so I can foresee in the future
that when we get the facility which
we'll have for sure I mean ultimately
you can get a test that could do this
reasonably easy and do the kind of what
we call zero surveillance study this is
very analogous that dr. Burks and I were
talking about that a lot and that is
back in the day when she and I were both
doing the hiv/aids issues back when we
first discovered the virus in 83 and we
had an antibody test in 1985 we found
out by the serial surveillance
represented seven different populations
that we were dealing with the tip of the
iceberg when we saw individuals who were
the ones who actually got infected it
gave us a really good feel for how many
people were infected how many are doing
well and how many are getting ill I
foresee that we'll have that same sort
of information which will be important
information but right now that's not our
immediate problem
let me just follow up with that because
I think as I discussed before we had
great I just want to thank all the
epidemiologists and scientists out there
who worked with us over the last four
weeks on models they really many came
forward and really supported us right
now we're in talks with the whole series
of universities we have the most
brilliant scientists in the world and
our universities in state after state
some of them public health universities
some of them basic science all of them
have received NIH grants for HIV or
other development of assays in the past
I've talked to a lot of them over the
last few days to really ask them to
develop these simple iliza tests that
could be used rapidly in their health
care centers because immediately with a
test it's easy to do we've all developed
eliza's so in a day or two after
development they could screen their
entire Hospital I think that would be
very reassuring to the health care
workers who have been on the frontline
we worry about them every day and so I
really called on every University in
every state to develop eliza's you can
buy the antigens and the controls online
and really work to test entire
healthcare communities in your States
and support them that way at the same
time we worked in sub-saharan Africa and
what we call dried blood spots so we're
looking at could you use that in a
community while we work on the
point-of-care test where you just dot
blood on to this paper and then that can
go into the lab and be analyzed that
would allow us to look in nursing homes
and other get long-term care facilities
immediately and then finally we've
reached out to the developers of the
rapid tests the ones who developed it
for malaria the ones that develop them
for HIV it's exactly the same concept
and process to ask them to rapidly
develop these tests because I think we
owe it to the frontline healthcare
providers not only to provide them RNA
tests but many of them have been on the
front line now for for weeks may have
become exposed we now know there's
asymptomatic and I think really being
able to tell the
the peace of mind that would come from
knowing you already
we're infected you have the antibody
you're safe from reinfection 99.9
percent of the time and so this I think
would be very reassuring to our
frontline health care workers and our
universities can do that by Friday so
I'm putting that challenge out to them
to really work on that and do that
that's what we did in the early days we
had Eliza's up and running within days
of having the antigen and so this is
what's really possible so we're not
waiting we're asking for help now
eventually this could happen soon even
within this monsoon within this month
if the universities help us absolutely
[Music]
religious groups can meet together and
that doesn't really agree who can
religious groups like your beginning man
but he did speak to me this morning
doctor please sir does that go against
your model because that's not full of it
I don't know I'd have to look at what he
did care workers on the front lines
following up with dr. Bert's as well
hazard pay you have said you have wanted
that for the health care workers on the
front lines I know secretary Manisha Nez
mentioned something about that possibly
in the North level the stimulus I like
it but can you make it happen now do we
have to wait for a fourth slow I think
it's something we're discussing in terms
of bonus or bonus pay it doesn't have to
be called hazard pay kit because hey
look I watched those people go into
hospitals that I know I talked about one
of them right but I watch them walk into
those hospitals and they walk in men
women young middle-aged not so many
older ones and I walk I watch them
they're almost like and I think I take
the word almost after they're like
warriors they're going in people are
cheering whether there's a building
across the street the people are
screaming that laughing there they're
like heroes
the Empire State no no I will tell you I
think it's incredible
they're like they're like warriors
they're like soldier
and we're gonna be doing something for
him but so whether it's bonus because
you know we're hopefully gonna be over
this relatively quickly it's gonna be
vicious for a period of time but
hopefully we're gonna be over this you
have a lot of questions saying look at
you there's you know this young man
you've never met her before there are a
lot of people who are worried about
getting sick and do they end up in a
hospital people who are uninsured and
will they be crushed by medical bills
you were considering last month last
month already in March reopening the
healthcare.gov exchanges there has been
a determination not to do that could you
tell us what the rationale was behind
that and and what what you have is an
alternative okay they took that up under
the task force and make well thank you
mr. president and what I can tell you is
that the president has made a priority
from the outset of our task force work
make sure every American knows that they
can have a corona virus and they don't
have to worry about the cost and we were
very inspired as well because of the
president's engagement with the leading
health insurance companies in the
country that now so far two of the top
health insurance companies in America
have announced that they're not only
willing to waive co-pays on testing and
now testing is fully covered because of
the bill the President signed for every
American but also their these two
insurance companies have waived co-pays
on all coronavirus treatment and I can
assure you that as Congress and the
president and the administration begin
to discuss the next piece of legislation
we're gonna make sure that Americans
have those costs compensated and cover
our priority right now is is is ensuring
that every American takes the 30 days to
slow the spread to heart the best thing
we can do for one another for our
family's health for the most vulnerable
among us is practice
of those mitigation strategies that the
president outlined yesterday for the
next 30 days we're dealing with testing
to make sure that every American can
have a test that needs one we're dealing
we're dealing with supplies and we're
making great progress in building
personal protective equipment and
ensuring that ventilators are available
particularly for the communities most
impacted but the American people can be
confident that as we move into this
we're going to make sure that our health
care workers are properly compensated
for their extraordinary and courageous
work and and we'll make sure that the
financial burden on those who end up
contracting the coronavirus and dealing
with its most serious symptoms also can
be you can can deal with those issues
and deal with those costs understood mr.
vice president but there will be people
who don't have insurance who get sick
before any of these mitigation efforts
are put into place and without opening
the health care exchanges where can they
find insurance people who aren't insured
by these companies that are covering the
cost of the copay where can people go
now to get health insurance if they get
before these well all across America we
have Medicaid for underprivileged
Americans and at the president's
Direction the Center for Medicaid
Medicare Services has given
unprecedented waivers for states to
expand coverage or coronavirus testing
and treatment we've also extended
waivers for Medicare Administration to
make sure that people have access to
that coverage but we're going to
continue to bring opportunities to the
president the traditional systems of
Medicaid in particular for the uninsured
in America to cover middle class well
the I think what we're seeing health
insurance companies do today John is
really inspiring I mean one of the one
of the things that I'm certain of the
president's approach for you who already
have insurance well
thingsit's that has animated and
characterized the president's approach
is the way he's engaged American
businesses to step up and do their part
and as the president said many times
we're we're inspired by the spirit of
American businesses I was at a
distribution center for Walmart today in
southern Virginia and I saw the way this
company that literally has already hired
thousands of people these workers are
coming to work the truck drivers are
coming to work farmers are working in
the field
grocery stores made a commitment of the
president a month ago that no grocery
store in America would close down the
food supply is strong we're getting food
on the table of every American but it's
because the president went to these
leaders and said we need you to step up
and do your part we we engaged health
insurance executives early on in this
process to wave to waive co-pays on
coronavirus testing and and because of
the engagement and frankly because of
that that patriotic and compassionate
spirit that's being reflected we've
already seen two of the largest
insurance companies in the country
announced that they're going to
providing full coverage free of charge
for coronavirus treatment I fully expect
I think as the president does too that
we'll see more of that for people that
have insurance will continue to provide
flexibility for Medicaid for people that
don't have insurance and we'll make sure
that Medicare has a flexibility to meet
this moment for seniors and when we
remember that seniors with underlying
health conditions are the are the most
vulnerable to serious outcomes from the
coronavirus but we'll get through this
using the full weight of the federal
government and the full strength of the
American economy though and it's
something we're really gonna look at
because it doesn't seem fair if you
having the other big advantage and it's
a certain income level you do I think
it's one of the greatest answers I've
ever heard because Mike was able to
speak for five minutes and not even
touch this work
no I said I said that's what you call a
great profession I mean just in terms of
a fair question I always endeavor to ask
better questions but this is a huge
worry yeah for people in this country
who were in that doughnut hole well you
don't have they don't have commercial
insurance they don't qualify for
Medicaid what do they think we're
looking at the entire 2000 election
talking about the doughnut hole and it's
still there yeah we are I haven't been
up there yet you know yeah other people
have been talking about it and they
haven't spoken this was 20 years ago
we're talking about but they're talking
about if they're talking about it I know
what they're talking about in the 2020
election - and nobody's gotten to it
nobody's talked about it at all mr.
president I think we will yeah I think
we're going to get to it I think we're
gonna get to it I don't I don't think
the other group will get to it
they haven't even spoken about it and
it's a big group of people I can't
commit I have to get approval from it I
have a thing called Congress but it's
something we're gonna look at and we
have been looking at it you mentioned in
this congressional bill the next the
sort of phase for you would like to see
something if there is a phase four but
we're certainly looking at certain
things we want to help restaurants
entertainment we want to help because
it's jobs that that restaurants it's
jobs tremendous amounts of jobs so we're
looking at that we're looking at
infrastructure and we think of it we
will have spent eight trillion dollars
and you know way back we're way pulled
back but we will have spent eight
trillion dollars in the middle east and
yet our roads are in bad shape our
bridges or tunnels the bad shape and
we're gonna be the talk of the world
again soon but we want to trillion we
will have spent in the Middle East and
all we got out of it was death and cost
but all we got our was death millions of
people you have to look at the other
side too millions and millions of people
killed our great soldiers thousands
killed so many wounded hurt and yet when
we want to go and fix
Road someplace we want to do what we
want to do in our cut you know it's time
that we spend money on our country
that's what we're gonna do it's time
that we start spending on our roads and
our bridges and our schools and all of
the things that we're supposed to be
spending on and people are finally
getting used to it and you could look at
all of what we've done in the Middle
East
way back in so many different places way
back in other countries too by the way
and I've gone to other countries that
are very rich I said I'm sorry you're
gonna have to reimburse us for our cost
they don't even want to know what I'm
talking about it takes them 20 minutes
to figure it out because nobody's ever
asked them to do that and they're doing
it they're doing it and they have no
choice they have to do it so it's time
that we start spending on the USA okay
please mr. president this is a question
for the vice president on March 9 you
said 1 million tests had been delivered
and another 4 million would be delivered
by the end of the week that clearly had
not happened what happened with those
projections well I think the test kits
were delivered according to HHS but the
difference is between receiving a test
and the ability to rapidly produce a
result of that test and frankly because
of the public-private partnership that
the president initiated now more than a
month ago with our massive commercial
laboratories across the country
our team was reported today that we're
now doing more than a hundred thousand
tests a day more than 1.2 million tests
have been performed states have
established drive-thru sites all across
the country in fact States have been so
successful with the community-based and
drive-through testing that we're working
to transition over completely all of the
federal work on Drive through testing
and and have the states completely
managed that process but 4 million tests
were delivered by the unit that week
HHS was very busy from early in the year
delivering test kits around the country
but the difference was as the president
said many times we had an antiquated
system where a state laboratory or CDC
only had
capacity to process forty to sixty tests
a day now with the commercial labs
literally those labs are processing tens
of thousands of tests every day and so
while we're continuing to distribute
test kits around the country now because
of the partnership with with companies
like Roche and and quest and LabCorp the
American people are seeing the results
of those tests more rapidly than at any
point in the past and we expect that
will continue to expand but the exciting
news this weekend about Abbott
Laboratories having a fifteen-minute
test approved is going to put us in a
position we believe down the road to get
to where dr. Fauci and dr. Burks want us
to be for many of the states that don't
yet have significant outbreak there's
some 19 states where we don't have
significant outbreak but we want to be
doing the kind of surveillance testing
in those states that will allow us early
on to identify people with the corona
virus do what the experts call contact
tracing and ensure that in that state we
don't have we don't have an outbreak of
the corona virus so in many countries
all of the world wanted to know whether
or not they could use especially our new
test that we that was just developed by
Abbott which is almost instantaneous
which is going to be great and remember
this we inherited the biggest we
inherited bad tests we inherited bed
tuffsy so harmful tests and it was
broken it was all broken and we fixed it
and we're doing millions of tests
sometimes we send out a test and it's
not used in many cases it wasn't used
but we worked with the states and the
testing has been pretty amazing
especially considering the fact that we
inherited a very broken system chip but
something you said before
are you considering a temporary ban on
all domestic flights I am looking at
hotspots I am looking where flights are
going into hot spots some of those some
of those flights I didn't like from the
beginning but closing up every single
flight on every single airline that's a
very very very rough decision but we are
thinking about hot spots where you go
from spot to spot both hot and we'll let
you know fairly soon about rail a
similar thing we have trains going back
and forth and people don't think of
trains but we do a lot of transportation
business it's a very big decision to do
that and we're pretty late in the
process from the standpoint that this is
starting you're going to start seeing I
think over the next couple of weeks
you're gonna start to see us hit it up
and start coming down so we'll make
those decisions those are very very
those are very very big decisions from
the standpoint of of the future of our
country in a way in the future of our
country we have to get our country back
we have to start moving again we have to
start working again now they're doing
tests on Airlines very strong tests
we're getting on getting off they're
doing tests on trains getting on getting
off but when you start closing up entire
transportation systems and then opening
them up that's a very tough thing to do
there continues to be a lot of public
confusion about the use of masks what is
the one we use
I love the sterilization of the mask so
Ohio company you can sterilize a the n95
you can you can sterilize that mask for
up to 20 times think of that up to 20
times we're throwing them out and
they're very expensive masks they're
throwing them out and I kept saying one
of the first questions I asked to dr.
Fauci I said why aren't they sterilized
or cleaning the masks because I didn't
you know was it my thing exactly when we
first heard about this nobody else know
it either and now we have a company and
I guess the number of companies one in
Ohio a great one that makes equipment
where you can sterilize a mask
220 times which is fantastic okay you or
me what about the public should we be
wearing masks out we've heard lots of it
I don't believe look there's a big thing
a lot of people don't like it some
people don't like it because you're
taking it away from the medical
professional some people don't like it
for other reasons I don't see where it
hurts
and it doesn't have to be a mask it can
be a scarf scarf is highly recommended
by the professionals I don't see where
it hurts I think if frankly if people
wanted to do it we don't want to do
anything that's gonna take masks you're
talking about a tremendous amount of
masks when you do that we don't want to
take them away from our medical
professionals but I certainly don't see
it hurting but what I do see people
doing now is using scarfs and I think in
a certain way depending on the fabric I
think in a certain way of scarf is
better it's actually better some
churches as you know have continued to
hold services even though you have
advised people that they need to
practice social distancing there was a
pastor of a mega church in Florida over
the weekend who held services that were
that were attended by several hundred
people so my question to you is should
pastors be holding services in the
middle of this pandemic and even if they
do should Americans be going well my
biggest disappointment is that churches
can't meet in a time of need you know
this is really a great time for churches
to be together for people to get
together on a Sunday or whenever any day
and meet and yet if you do that if you
do it close you're really giving this
invisible enemy a very big advantage so
it's it's the biggest I think the single
biggest disappointment is you can't one
of the reasons I said wouldn't it be
great just to pick a date as you know I
called it aspirational and aspirational
date would be Easter and I will tell you
it's a it's very very disappointing but
again you get too close and if
somebody's sick you're gonna probably
catch it so you have to be very careful
quickly Joe Biden's campaign came out
the statement today so Biden Biden would
be he write the statement would get some
PR person as far as I know the campaign
was wide awake sir and he said they sent
a statement that Joe Biden would be open
to having a phone call with you to talk
about the coronavirus mnsure would you
take his call about history computer I'd
like I'd be in touch he should be here
together i I always have him to be a
nice guy I don't know him very well
frankly but I think he's is probably a
nice guy know he'd like to call it
absolutely take his cool okay you could
tell him you have talked about the
failings of the administration in
leaving you with empty shelves and no
plans well there's no I'm gonna shoot
think we didn't do that that turned out
to be a false stories now you're
starting to go
what are you working for CNN I'm
pointing out what they have said what
you have to do it with us the Fox isn't
so easy either don't kid yourself
president look John let me tell you
something you see you know that's a
false story what you just said is a
false story this doctor knows it better
than anybody know but you shouldn't be
repeating a story that you know is false
all right who's next
what's that an economy under which
conditions would you consider suspending
save US sanctions well look we have to
talk to them I think we could work out a
deal with a run very quickly all they
have to do is call I just think that you
know they're proud people and the
leadership is proud that crowds like all
of us we're proud you people are proud
they're having a hard time picking up
the phone or they're having a hard time
setting up the meeting but they could
fix their country pretty easily and we
don't want hostility but if they are
hostile to us they're going to regret it
like they've never regretted anything
before as per today's statement but all
they have to do is call or have somebody
call you know there are channels where
we can deal very easily again I think
that John Kerry did a tremendous
disservice I think
violated the Logan Act a hundred percent
that's what I think and I think it made
it tough for them because they were
dealing with him for years it was a
terrible deal all of that money 150
billion dollars plus cash plus cash
plane loads of cash for a deal that was
no good and was short-term essentially
it was a short-term deal who makes a
deal for that kind of money and 1.8
billion dollars in cash I don't even
know what that would look like that
would be this room would have to be
filled up five times with hundred-dollar
bills okay who makes it deal like this
and then on top of it the deals no good
all right how about one or two more
reported a surging calls about domestic
violence a number of groups of grace
because our Mexican Vernors domestic
violence a number of concerns that the
longer people are stuck at home the more
domestic violence cases there are going
to be do you share those concerns and
what is being done is pictures and how
the cost of of not getting our country
working I mean people are now some
people are getting along great I've also
had the up at the exact opposite
question people families are coming
together they're actually coming
together they haven't talked for a long
time and now all of a sudden they're
talking again they're loving each other
so I've heard that too but I also have
heard domestic violence much you know at
a higher level and drug use because of
in this case they'd lose their jobs they
had a great job they had a great life
they have a great family all of a sudden
a husband's told that he doesn't have a
job anymore and he's got no money and
that brings drugs into it that brings
suicide into it it's a terrible thing we
have to get our country going again we
did the right thing we had no choice we
did the right thing other countries
tried to use the heard or the herd
mentality it's just you know something
that doesn't work if you look at I mean
just to say I heard Sweden gave it a
shot and they won they saw things that
were really frightening and they went
immediately to shutting down the country
we did the right thing and we did it
early we did it earlier
stuffed other people from coming into
our country early but but no that's a
cost that's a I've been talking about
that people say what are you talking
about but you will have you'll have that
you'll have domestic violence you have
violence you'll have suicide you'll have
drug addiction a lot of people are going
to be lost we want to get this open as
soon as we can I mean I'll be the
happiest person so will you everyone in
this room happy when we get the word
that this is the time and we have our
common sense and they'll give me a
decision or they'll be making certain
statements and I think I'll know how to
interpret those statements very well
I'll be with Mike I'll be with the task
force I'll be with a lot of very
talented people including the two people
on stage with us but I look forward
that'll be a great day that'll be a
great day all right how about one more
please
what is the current contingency planning
nice attention centers where cases of
copy 19 are already probably not some
people have been release is there a
contingency planet would you release
it'll most vulnerable people like
children at the elder well ice looks at
on a case-by-case basis even well before
kovat on looking at certain detention
facilities and determine on a
case-by-case basis if they need do need
to release individuals and when we do
that we awfully put them on alternatives
to detention as well in the case of
kovat we're looking at vulnerable
populations and again ice is doing that
in conjunction with CDC and other
medical professionals in some cases we
do need to do that for the health and
safety and the well-being of those
detainees but again that's a
case-by-case basis we're not going to
make any blanket statement that we're
going to release individuals of whole
groups at a time so it's really
important and I've said it through twice
now it's a really a case-by-case basis
determining the health of that
particular population or detainee the
the facility they're in different
facilities have different capabilities
whether it's a nice own to facility or
it's a contractor own facility and so
we're certainly doing that we're doing
that today we've done been doing that
for the past several weeks
absolutely we have continued to build
miles of the wall every day we're up to
over 150 I believe we're continuing to
build new new miles of wall and a lot of
folks asked about replacement wall or
new miles and it's a new capability on
our southwest border that we haven't had
before so whether you talk to the agents
the Border Patrol agents they like that
capability like they like that impedance
and denial that it provides them and it
provides the ability for those agents to
focus elsewhere on parts of the border
that are very difficult to patrol so we
can use our resources in a different way
and so we see a lot of benefits from the
border wall system and again that
includes not only the physical
infrastructure but the cameras the roads
the Lighting's the fiber-optic cables
and we're looking forward and we're
still well on our track well on our mark
to meet for
450 miles by the end of the calendar
year for me while here there's been
concern among farmers about being able
to get enough migrant labor to keep the
food supply moving as we go into the
harvest season what are you doing to
address that well at the direction of
the vice-president and the task force we
are looking at a number of different
options with the h-2a workers that you
mentioned on how do we either extend the
validity of their visa or looking at a
couple of different options nothing to
announce here today but again out the
direction of the president the vice
president we're looking at a very
variety of different options that I
think we will have soon and will be very
beneficial because we want the farmers
they've had this for years we want the
farmers to be able to get the people
that have been working those farms for
years so we're not gonna have farms so
they're gonna come in and they're going
to be given a certain pass and we're
gonna check them very very closely
especially over the next month because
remember after a month or so I think
once this passes we're not gonna have to
be hopefully worried too much about the
virus but we want them to come in we're
not closing the border so that we can't
get any of those people to come in
they've been there for years and years
and I've given the commitment to the
farmers they're gonna continue to come
well we're not going to have any farmers
okay with people looking at the two
ships yeah we have a we have Canada
notified a lot of Canadians a lot of
British on the ship and they're coming
to take the people that are on the ship
back to their homeland
Canada's coming a UK is coming and we
have a lot of and we have Americans we
have some people that are quite sick and
we're taking care of that I'm speaking
with the governor about that a lot and
it's a tough situation it's a tough
situation you know you can understand
you have people that are sick on those
ships and states don't want to take they
have enough problems right now they
don't want to take them but we have to
from a humane standpoint we don't have a
choice
it's like I don't want to do that but we
have to people are dying
we're gonna do something we're gonna do
something at a minimum we're sending
medical teams on board the ships we're
taking the Canadians off and giving them
to Canadian authorities they're going to
bring them back home the same thing with
the UK but we have to help the people
there they're in big trouble
no matter where no matter where they're
from happen to be Americans largely
Americans but whether they were or not I
mean they're dying so we have to do
something and and the governor knows
that you were being sent on well we're
sending a lot of amamiya we're sending a
lot of our home to their countries but
we'll be doing something and we'll be
announcing it you'll see what we're
doing but we're also putting medical
staff onto the ships so that we can we
have to take care of the people but the
risk of you getting chewed out again mr.
president there is a the IRS is
requiring people who don't normally file
income tax to file a simple income tax
return in order to get their $1200 check
is that the way it's going to be is
there something you can do I had heard
that now I don't know do you know that
sounds like it's not well good we could
get back yeah it's being it's a process
that they're working on we'll get back
to you as soon as we find out all right
one more please he's great he's a great
guy and he's doing a wonderful job from
Brazil welcome this morning just a very
complimentary call he's working very
hard he's got a problem with the virus
got a big problem and he's we talked
about it today at length we had a call
this morning and Brazil is shut down as
you know they weren't going to shut it
down but they had to so Brazil is shut
down
the world is shut down nobody's ever
seen anything like this the entire world
is shut down you go from having the most
powerful economy in the world and from
other countries that are doing well to
being everything you shut down
it's very sad but we're gonna get it
going and we're gonna be stronger than
ever I really believe that we're gonna
be stronger we're gonna have a big
bounce a very big bounce when this is
gone and I just want to thank the
American people I want to thank these
great professionals and I want to thank
the media because really for the most
part the media has been very